hey leute bevor es mit dem video losgeht
eine kurze ansage ich hab das video
nachts um zwei aufgenommen ich war sehr
müde und ich habe in dem video einige
einige extreme dinge rausgehauen also
lengefeld grenzwertig sind die manche
leute nicht verstehen werden und
deswegen vorher jungen zuschauer ist
vielleicht nicht das video für euch ich
mache jetzt einfach mal so eine gedachte
altes geschenk war 14 hier drauf als
wenn ihr junge ist dann ist fällt
wirklich nicht euer video und ja ich
hoffe ihr wissen es zu schätzen wenn
lieber einfach mal frei seine meinung
gesagt und somit euch redet als würde
mit seinem besten kumpel werden ich habe
wirklich einfach frei von der leber
geredet also ja ich unterstütze herzlich
willkommen ich bin hier gerade wie ihr
seht in einem raum bin ich aber dass ich
irgendwann wollte ich bin heute in
berlin und das hotelzimmer
ich hab auf toto ist gefragt hätte schon
mal ein video gemacht durch dieses
kleine formate bisschen aufpeppen wollte
weil die gleichen fragen kommen warum
heißt der kanal wie du heißt ist mag es
wirklich dein bruder ihr euch gebeten
mir fragen zu stellen die ich
normalerweise nicht trauen würde zu
fragen weil ich finde dass man das
kriminell ein bisschen spannender
deswegen habt ihr mir wieder einige
ordentliche bretter reingehauen hier die
leute ich hab es folgten hier gesund
french gelten plätze sieht das selbe
staus in der kammer sowie bekommt eine
lehrerin sie aufrecht hin hob althoffs
kd fragt könntest du dir eine beziehung
mit max vorstellen
und wenn nicht
ein anderer youtube plus begründung
fragezeichen xt ok hop cooler avatar
übrigens bin ich das als ausdruck randow
okay nein in cee cis nein einfach nein
und ein anderer youtuber geld
kurze frage was nur auf rang drei ich
weiss ist jetzt direkt männliche bist du
eigentlich heißt aber ich kann es
vielleicht so beantworten was ich jetzt
überhaupt kein youtuber kenne der mich
persönlich interessieren würde ich sagen
würde
egal ob männlich oder weiblich der stopp
mit dem sollten wir mal besser kann halo
kein doppel elli fragt wie viel sex
träume hattest du schon mal acht lebend
kostenfalle warum bist du so scheiß
lachender smiley würde dich zwar sonst
auf fragen aber okay es liegt daran dass
und verdammt ist
welche straftat würdest du machen wenn
du nicht bestraft werden würde mord ich
würde auf jeden fall ein paar leute
umlegen aber ganz sicher so ein paar
leute hier irgendwie person die er so
richtig überhaupt nicht leiden kann bei
manchen geht's weiter so weit dass das
dann über die pillen denkt dass sie
nicht so wirklich eine berechtigung zum
leben hat und dir einfach alles zu krass
youtube gelöscht
blaue parker fragt sehr ernst gemeinte
frage und eine frau
wie findest du es dass meine
gastschwester einführungs zeichnet seit
drei stunden im party aus knoll ist
sauer
wenn deine gast störte seit drei stunden
offenbart ist würde ich vielleicht mal
die tür aufbrechen checken ob sie noch
lebt gut das war gar nicht die frage war
wie finde ich es super
gute aktion von altersschwäche schaut ja
den acker frage hast du schon mal was
mit einem mädchen gemacht was dem
nachnamen und definitiv meine füße wie
film da drüben auch darüber erst gar
nicht gefragt hast du dir mal die frage
gestellt ob du vielleicht schwul sein
könntest wollen ich weiß nicht ob das ob
es anderen auch so geht aber die feier
wird tatsächlich schon mal gestellt
perfekt ist sondern auch normal sagt die
vize passiert aber ja was auf jeden fall
ich auch gern so dinger raus also ich
bin gern offen mit mainz schon erzählt
gern sind darf oder so aber welcher
youtube würde sich trauen so was ein
video zu sagen ich hab's aber mal raus
und ich hoffe dass damit umgehen könnt
und zum abschluss leute eine
wunderschöne freiheit meine ersten
tollen den von china an gina pakt war
deine erste freundin hässlich es ist
eine gute frage alter leute ich hab
einem anderen video erzählt dass die
einen ultra peinlichen kurs mit meiner
ersten freundin gab also schulen weil
sie nebeneinander meyn gymnasium hier
ihre realschule hier zwischen den
schulhof da wird immer getroffen mit
einer 90 euro und einer pause kommt sie
zu mir
wir begrüßen es wird einem kuss
es war so das war so etwas denkt warum
wurde ich geboren so richtig nah und die
war ihm auch hässlicher es klingt
gemeinde ist zu sagen aber erst freunde
weil ich würde schon sagen alles nicht
bisschen gemein ist zu sagen auf dem
markt welche das drücke siehst du da
irgendwas nicht so sicher bin ganz
leicht das ist wirklich nicht was man
mit den augen nicht sehen kann ist schon
da vorne drin
ja das ist so wichtig dass ich die
kamera sehen kann mit dem bloßen auge
sieht man da kein licht das einfach nur
stoff schwarz neues live video von emrah
wenn s life hey leute ich bin's livni
und heute zeige ich euch an wunder und
lag mit dem licht von fernbedienung
sinken
ja leute das war's von dem heutigen
spiel wir haben auf jeden fall ein paar
ordentliche dinge ausgabe ich sagen das
setting hier ist fucking random einfach
dem hotelzimmer ich habe scheiße gebaut
heute leute gebe ich zu aber gefährliche
dinge rausgehauen und verantwortung
gegeben die andere geht so nicht geben
würden oder ja einfach ein paar
außergewöhnliche antwort gegeben und ich
habe das video an euch unterhalten
setting ist ja ich weiß es nicht
nochmals aufnahme zimmer aber zum
ausgleich
hier ist ein weißes blatt papier kann
das schon wieder ausgleichen ich sage ja
long story short leute ich hab das
kleine rede halten danke an alle
fragesteller
hier soll man das unsichtbare licht bis
zum nächsten video
irgendwie schon so